[Music]
always remember the universe has a way
of leading into where you're supposed to
be at the moment you're supposed to be
there let's do this took me 20 years to
find you how many people can say that
you are the best-kept secret in the
universe and I found you
which makes me perfect for this job
you really think a black suit it's going
to solve all your problems
no but looks damn good on you we are
recognizable only as deja vu and
dismissed just as quickly time to prove
yourself agent M we may have a problem
in London welcome to my brief you will
be with Asian Paints one of the best
ever to wear this suit catching up on my
daily meditation time for lunch oh thank
you hungry it's 9:30
it's Tuesday's taco day
we be compromised is every citizen of
this planet at risk
[Music]
if you could all just look right here
just try
gonna be fun left fun with it
it should be a big red button around
here somewhere found it we are the men
in black
looks like the tables have turned
I was incredible
you